[MUSIC PLAYING]
SLAWEK WALKOWSKI: Lightweight,
fast, highly available.
This is how serverless
is often described.
And it's all true, but making
your solution reliable--
and performance--
depends also on you.
Hi, I'm Slawek.
I work as a software engineer
in the Cloud Functions team
at Google.
And together with
my colleague Marek,
we will talk about ways to
build solid production systems
with Cloud Functions.
Now, Cloud Functions is
an event-driven serverless
computer platform.
Someone or something
generates an event,
and your code, your function,
is executed as a result of it.
This is pretty much
the simplest way
to run your code in the cloud.
There are no servers to be
provisioned, managed, patched,
or updated.
You pay only while
your code runs.
You can connect and extend
multiple cloud services.
And finally, Cloud
Functions automatically
scale, are highly available,
and fault tolerant.
But does it mean that all
your potential problems
with availability
and performance
are automatically resolved?
The answer is not
completely, as you can still
apply multiple best practices
to build a robust system.
And we're going to talk
about them in this talk.
First we will cover
reliability improvements,
then we move on to
performance optimizations,
and additionally, we will
also discuss observability,
which is important when
you want to know what
is going on with your system.
Let's start with talking
over reliability improvements
through making
your Cloud Function
retryable and idempotent.
We first need to realize
that in distributed systems
failures happen.
In fact, they are an inherent
part of such systems,
as it's practically impossible
to build a solid production
system or any complex system
in which errors do not
occur at all.
The only way we
can handle them is
to make sure that we handle
the errors gracefully,
and cloud platform actually
provided significant help
in handling such errors.
It is actually one of
the big benefits of using
cloud and server solutions.
However, your
software still needs
to be prepared for
error scenarios.
If we think about who
ensures reliability
of your software
running in the cloud,
we realize that
reliability must be
a shared goal across the cloud
platform and your solution.
When you use a
Google Cloud Service,
Google takes care
of its reliability.
For example, when you
call a cloud Vision API,
Google makes sure that the
service is available and can
handle your request.
When you upload a
file to cloud storage,
Google makes sure it's
persistent using replication
under the hood.
When you create your
service in the cloud,
Google still helps you
build a robust system,
but you are in control of
its overall reliability.
For example, your function
may fail if it includes a bug.
A call to your other
service may also
fail if that service returns
an error or is flaky.
How to ensure reliability
of your Cloud Function.
As we already know, functions
are good for processing events.
In particular,
they're a great tool
when connecting different
services, for example,
when processing
the incoming data
and uploading it to
a storage system.
In the success scenario,
everything works.
The data is processed and
then persisted, for example,
in a database.
But what if an error
occurs in this process?
Your function may
run out of memory.
A network connectivity
issue may happen.
You may get an error
response from the service
on which you depend.
All these issues may
potentially result in data loss
if the data doesn't make
it to its destination.
How to handle
problems like this.
Retries are an
important strategy here.
In a distributed
system, it is normal
that the services on which
your function depends
are not always 100% available.
As a result, your function
may fail occasionally.
The simplest way to handle
failures in serverless
is to retry function executions.
However, you should
not force your users
to retry requests
through your system,
but instead you should configure
your system to perform retries
automatically when needed.
Cloud Functions come in
two distinct variants.
HTTP functions are invoked
by standard HTTP requests,
which wait for HTTP
response from the function.
Background functions
are involved
by events from the clouds, like
messages from a cloud pub/sub
topic, or changes in a
Cloud Storage bucket.
All functions are normally
invoked once for an event,
unless an error occurs.
And here is where the two
variants of Cloud Functions
offer different
execution guarantees.
HTTP functions are executed
at the most once due
to their synchronous nature.
This means that the calls are
not retried by cloud functions,
and it is the caller who
must handle any errors.
And if you think
about it, the caller
should handle the errors anyway,
as the request might not even
reach Google's infrastructure.
On the other hand,
background functions
are executed at least once,
as asynchronous function
executions triggered
by events can
be retried by cloud functions,
as there is no caller who
could do it otherwise.
Let's look at some examples.
This is an HTTP function
which calls another service
to upload the payload
from the HTTP requests.
It simply sends a post
request to that service.
Easy, right?
The problem is that the
call to the other service
may fail for whatever
reason, for example, network
connectivity issue, and this
would result in the function
failure, and if the
function isn't retried then
the data may be
dropped on the floor.
In the case of HTTP
functions, the calls
should be retried by the caller.
So you can change
your caller's codes
to either implement
your own retry logic,
or use an existing library or
module that can perform retries
for you, for example,
in this case,
the promise retry module retries
the calls to Cloud Function,
because we return the request
promise inside the promise
retry call.
This is a simple
background function.
It also uploads data
to another system.
This time it
extracts the contents
from the Cloud Pub/Sub
message payload.
Similar problem here-- if
the dependent service fails,
the function will fail
because we turned the promise
as the function result.
In the case of
background functions
retries should be configured
on function deployments,
either through Cloud
SDK or Cloud Console,
by enabling the retry
on failure option.
This way, your function will
be retried until it succeeds.
The first retry happens
almost immediately
after the first
function execution.
The next retry follows the
exponential backoff policy,
capped at 10 seconds, and they
happen for up to seven days
if your function keeps failing.
However, you should be
careful with using this option
because it will retry your
function on any error,
also if it is caused by a bug
or some unexpected input data.
So if you use this option,
you should return errors
from your function only
on transient issues
and preferably handle
the permanent problems
inside the functions completely.
So in general there are multiple
places to apply retries.
As we saw, you can retry
calls to an HTTP function.
You can configure retries
of the background functions.
You can also retry calls
to dependent systems
from inside the function.
For example, by configuring the
client libraries that you use,
you can search for what
options they offer,
or you can write custom code.
And finally, as
already mentioned,
persistent errors
should be distinguished
from transient failures, and
retries should be applied only
on the latter ones.
Let's look at a more
complex example now.
Here is a function
which processes the data
and writes it to two
storage systems--
first to the upper one,
and then to the lower one.
The problem is, as you may
expect, that any of the uploads
may fail.
For example, let's
assume that the upload
to the second storage fails.
Well, in this case,
the data would not
be saved in the storage, but we
know how to handle this, right?
Apply retries.
But are retries always safe?
For example here,
if we apply retries,
the second function
execution will
result in storing the data
in the second storage,
assuming that the upload
succeeds this time.
However, the first storage
will receive a duplicate
because the upload to the
first storage will be retried,
and duplicates
introduce inconsistency.
The inconsistencies,
they are not good,
so we don't want them.
Can we do anything to
prepare the function
for retry executions to avoid
issues like data duplication?
The answer is yes, and
the concept of idempotency
comes in handy here.
A function is
considered idempotent
if an event results in the
desired outcome and side
effects, even if the function
is invoked multiple times
for the same event.
So making a function
idempotent is actually
required to make
it behave correctly
on retry execution attempts.
Let's look at the
non-idempotent function first.
This function uploads
the received contents
to Firestore first, and then
it uploads the same contents
to another service by
sending a post request.
One potential problem
here is that if the upload
to the Firestore succeeds, and
the upload to the other service
fails, and the
function is retried,
another document with
the same contents
will be added to the
Firestore, so we'll
have a duplicate which can
also be seen in the Firestore
database viewer.
But this may also happen
if the Firestore was
replaced with another system.
And as we know, we
don't want duplicates.
They may introduce
further inconsistencies.
They may cause
accounting problems.
The users may be confused.
They are not good.
To solve this problem
we'll use event ID.
This is a number which
uniquely identifies each event,
and what is important here
is that even if the function
execution is retried
for the same event,
the event ID itself
remains unchanged.
How do we use it in our code?
We first extract the event
ID from the event context,
and then we use it as the
Firestore document ID.
This way if the
function is retried,
it will not add a
duplicate object
to Firestore-- a
duplicate document.
Instead it will overwrite
the existing document
which exists under the same
event ID with the same contents
anyway.
Similarly some other
systems also support
so-called idempotency keys.
And if the system that
you use supports them,
you can use event ID
as the idempotency key.
As a result we no longer observe
duplicates in the Firestore,
and similarly we will
not observe duplicate
in other systems to
which we pass the event
ID as the idempotency key.
But what if the system
on which we depend
does not support idempotency?
Here's an example.
This is a function which uses
SendGrid, the email delivery
service, to send an
email from the function.
The problem is that the
send call is not idempotent.
What can we do about it?
We can record the event IDs.
This is the general
approach here.
We use a database-- like
Firestore in this example,
but other database
could work as well--
to store the
already-handled event IDs.
And then when the requests
come, before we enter
the non-idempotent
section of the code--
so the one which sends an
email, and if it was retried,
it could result in
duplicate emails being sent.
In this section, we first
check by querying Firestore
whether the event was handled.
And if it was not, we execute
the non-idempotent section
and then store the event ID
as handles in the Firestore
database.
This way the chance
of unwanted retried
calls to the other service of
the duplicate emails being sent
are greatly reduced.
However, there is
still a small chance
that if the function attempts
are executed concurrently,
a duplicate email
may still be sent.
To practically
resolve this issue
we can use the lease mechanism.
It allows us to get
an exclusive access
to the non-idempotent
section of the code
for the specific amount of time.
In this example,
the first attempt
gets the lease before it
enters the critical section--
the one that sends the email.
The second attempt, which
happens while the lease is
taken, is actually rejected
because it cannot get
the lease.
And finally, the
third attempt, which
happens after the
first attempt failed,
takes the lease again,
and eventually succeeds
with handling the event.
How do we apply this
approach to our code?
We use a Firestore transaction.
And this time it not only
checks whether a given event has
been handled, but it also saves
the time stamp until which
the current function
execution has exclusive access
to that critical section--
again, the one which
sends the email.
If another request comes
before this time stamp--
I mean, another retry
of the same function--
it will be rejected.
So no concurrent code
execution will happen.
And with this approach
applied, we practically
eliminated the unwanted retries.
So to summarize, there
are multiple ways
to make your
function idempotent.
You can ensure that your
mutations can happen
more than once without
changing the outcome,
you can record which event IDs
have already been processed,
you can query database
states in the transaction
before mutating the state, you
can also supply idempotent keys
when calling APIs
which support them,
and finally you can also clean
up duplicates out of band
through an offline process,
if that approach is
fine in your workflow.
All right, so to see retrace
and idempotency in action,
I will demonstrate a
simple order processing
system for my fake
restaurant, called Kale Pizza.
How does it look like?
Going from the left
side of the diagram,
there's a website through which
customers can create orders.
The website invokes
one Cloud Function,
which publishes a message
to Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
Then there is another
function, which
is triggered on messages
from this topic,
and it does three things.
First it calls another
service represented
by another function, which
chooses the cook who's going
to handle the given order.
Then it stores the order
together with the selected cook
in the Firestore database.
And then it calls yet another
service, yet another function,
which triggers meal preparation.
And finally, the
restaurant has a website
which simply syncs with
the Firestore database
to view the incoming orders.
All right, so let's
see this in action.
OK, so I will click
start right away.
And here we have
these two websites.
So one is the client
website, and the other one
is the restaurant website.
So the one on the left
generates the event.
I'm generating them
every second here
to see more of these
events going out
to make it more interesting.
And let's see what we get here.
So far, so good.
All the retries
are going through.
OK, let's wait a bit more.
All right, let's stop it.
So what do we see now?
44 orders went out, and
only 41 orders came in.
So some orders got
lost here, and I
can see that, for example,
the first one here, right,
it didn't make it
to the restaurant.
It didn't make it through
the whole pipeline.
So something is
wrong here, and lost
orders means unhappy customers--
not good for your business.
So let's investigate
what happened.
So I have the functions
I've deployed in my project,
and the main function,
the one which
performs those three actions,
is the process order function.
And like I show in the
diagram, it does three things.
It calls the choose
cook service,
then it stores the
order in the database,
and then it calls
yet another service.
So probably something
failed here.
So let's see, and here is
where the observability tools
in Google Cloud
Platform are useful.
First, I can see that
on the executions chart,
there are some errors, indeed.
Most requests were OK, but
there are also some errors.
And if I scroll down, I can see
the errors from the last seven
days, and if I click here I go
to Stackdriver Error Reporting,
in which I can see
the errors chart.
I can see a simple stack trace.
And finally, I
can see some logs.
OK, let's go to this one--
or this one.
I can click View Logs,
and see the logs here.
All right, so if I filter
only by this execution ID,
I can see a simple
function invocation.
So the function execution
started, received an order,
but then it got
the transit failure
from the choose cook service.
And if we look at
the implementation
of the choose cook
function, we can
see that it's
implemented in a way that
only succeeds 90% of the time.
For the remaining 10%, it fails.
Of course, this is a synthetic
example of a failing service.
But as I said, you should assume
that the function that you're
calling or the service
that you're calling
may fail for many reasons.
And similar story about the
other function, prepare a meal,
it also has the success
ratio of 90% only.
All right, so we
know what happened,
and we know how to handle
transit issues, right.
We can apply retries.
So I have the second
version of this function
here, process order retry,
with the same source code.
It does the same thing,
but it has the retry
on failure option enabled.
I use this option when
deploying the function.
So let's see how this one works.
Let's switch to the topic Cloud
Pub/Sub topic and Firestore
collection, which
actually are operated
on by this second
version of the function.
All right, so I've got orders
going out, orders coming in.
By the way, the color are
just color-encoded event IDs
so that we can visually
compare the right and left side
and see the differences.
OK, I can stop.
And what do I see?
26 orders went out, and
30 orders came then, so--
OK, 31.
31 orders came in, so
definitely more than I sent.
So there must be
some duplicates,
and I can already
see some here which
appears even three times-- the
same order, the same event IDs,
with three different
cooks assigned.
So they may start preparing
the meal right away.
While the customer may be
happy with the extra two meals,
but still that's not
good for your business.
So what can we do to
avoid these duplicates?
And the answer is
introduce idempotency.
So I have the third
version of the function
here, and this time I
modified the source code.
And the piece that I modified
is the one which runs--
which stores the
order Firestore.
So I introduce a transaction
which first checks
whether the given event ID--
whether the document
with the given event ID,
or in this case the order
ID, was already processed.
And I only add it to Firestore
if it does not exist yet.
This way I also
prevent the issue
of overriding the same
order with a different crook
assigned.
So let's see how this one works.
So I have the
third version here.
Let's start
generating the event.
All right, it takes some
time to process them.
We should start
seeing them here.
All right, they're coming in.
Let's wait a bit more to see
if we get the desired results.
So far, so good.
Orders catching up.
Yep.
OK, so 29 orders generated,
29 orders came in.
So no lost orders
and no duplicates.
And I'd like to highlight that
I didn't touch the services that
were flaky, that failed
for 10% of the time,
but instead I reconfigured
the other parts
of the system to handle this
situation in a good way.
Moving on, I'd like to summarize
the first part of the talk,
saying that you should introduce
retries and make your function
idempotent to improve
reliability of your functions.
Thank you, and with
this I would like
to introduce my
colleague, Marek,
who is going to
cover the second part
of the talk about
performance optimizations.
MAREK BISKUP: Thank you, Slawek.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I'm very happy to
be here with you.
I wonder how many of you
actually use Cloud Functions
or have tried Cloud Functions.
OK, so this is going
to be a little bit--
it's not such a basic topic,
so I assume that all of you
know what the cold start is.
So I assume that all of you
know that the cold start is
when the infrastructure
brings up
a new instance that will execute
the cold feature function.
And you probably know
that this happens
if there's no instance that
is serving the traffic,
or maybe that there is a sudden
surge in the number of requests
that your function
has to handle,
and then there must be
many instances executing
at the same time.
You've probably heard that
functions are stateless,
and that's because there are
so many instances that came in
and come out.
And that's true, but the fact
is that they are not always
stateless, which means that if
there is an instance that it's
serving, it's
probably going to be
re-used for future invocations,
for subsequent calls.
And this lets you reuse the
state that the instance has
to improve performance.
And I will show you a little
bit how you can do that.
So the first example
is connections.
Let's assume that
your function has
to connect to some
external system,
and you can improve
performance by maintaining
persistent connections.
So you establish the connection
at the first function
invocation in the instance
that it's serving,
and then subsequent calls that
will hit the same instance
are going to have the
connection established.
So this may not be so important
if the system that you connect
to is in the same data
center or very close,
but it's very important if the
system that you are connecting
to is on the other
side of the world,
and then the connection
establishment actually
takes time.
And a small caveat
here is that you
have to be careful
with the target system
that you are connecting
to, because it
may have a limit on the
number of connections
that it can handle.
And if you use
persistent connections,
any instance of the
function that it's actually
out there serving will
maintain the connections.
So it may expose the connection
pool of the target system.
Going farther,
the same principle
may apply to API objects.
And such API objects
very often have
connections inside somewhere.
So it's very useful to
declare those API objects
on the global scope in the code
so that the connection is not
re-established every time
you create the API object.
Similarly, if there is
a global variable that
gets recomputed every time
your function is called,
it's useful to put it
into the global scope
so that it's completed
once and then reused
on the subsequent invocations.
But on the other hand,
it's not always true
that it's better to
perform those computations
in the global scope
on the cold start,
because it may happen that
the value is not even used.
So if you use the value
under very rare conditions,
it's better to compute it lazily
and not in the call thread
because the best optimisation
is when you just remove
the code that is not used.
And this is especially
important if your function--
if you declare several functions
in the same file, which
you can do.
And actually many people--
everyone that uses
Firebase probably
did that because this
is the common way how
Firebase functions are written.
And if you do that, you have to
know that every function runs
in a separate set of instances.
So if an instance
handles invocations
of the first function,
it will never
be called to execute
the second function,
because that's a separate
set of instances.
So if you initialize a
very heavy variable that
is used in the second
function in the global scope
it's just a waste of time.
And that also applies to
those require statements
in OJS where you
include libraries
that you are going to use.
So it's a bit awkward to require
libraries inside the function,
but if you declare
multiple functions
in the same file, that's a
performance optimization.
When you apply these
kind of optimizations,
please be mindful that
the function runs only
until the callback is called.
If you try to execute
something after it's called,
there will be no CPU
actually to do that,
and the code will not progress.
So it may be tempting to
write the code like this,
to send the result to the
customer-- to the user,
and then do some
computations to optimize
for subsequent invocations,
but don't do that.
It will not work.
I've told you about caching some
computations inside functions
in the global scope,
inside an OJS process,
but you can use also
a local file system
where you can write files.
And those files will survive
on this particular instance
as long as the instance
is alive and is serving.
But you have to be careful
here because the file
system is in memory.
So it's not infinite, and
every file that you write
is going to consume the runtime
memory of your function.
So eventually if
on every invocation
you create a new file, and
you forget to delete them,
you will run out of memory.
And when you run out of
memory your instance will die,
and this means that there
will be a cold start
for future invocations.
And of course, when
there is a cold start,
you lose the state
that you carefully
prepared inside this
instance to optimize
for subsequent invocations,
so it's better to avoid them.
And you can avoid
them by taking care
of not exceeding the
allocated memory,
not throwing any
uncalled exceptions.
Just catch those exceptions,
because sometimes
the process that executes
the code may actually crash
that also causes a cold start.
And when your
function times out,
also that instance is put down
and another one is started.
This all was about
caching computations
inside the instance.
That's executes your code.
And this cache, this
state, is available only
for this particular instance.
So you have to recompute it
in every other instances.
It's also possible to
go a little bit farther
to share some state
across all the instances.
But for that you need to use
some database, for instance,
a serverless database
like Firestore.
So the summary for
this part of the talk
is that you can leverage
the state of instances
to speed up subsequent
invocations,
and I'm going to show
you an example how
I managed to optimize a
little bit of my application
to just serve faster.
And the application
that I prepared
is converting text to images,
so it's applying caption
on the picture.
And the parameters for the
functions are just two--
the caption to be written and
whether we want some background
or not.
And we have very awkward
users that most often they
don't want any background.
They just prefer white picture.
And we are going to
optimize for this use case.
So what the function does--
first, it fetches the
background from Cloud Storage,
then it applies the
caption using ImageMagick,
and finally it uploads the
result also to Cloud Storage.
The code is simple, exactly
as you would probably imagine.
So create a temporary directory,
download the background file,
load the file into
memory, draw the caption,
write the file to disk, and
upload it to Cloud Storage.
Very simple, right?
And when we debug our
distributed application,
where we analyze what happens
in such an application,
it's very--
we just have to use
the platform tools
to observe what's going on.
So we are going to use Cloud
Logging and Monitoring to see
either logs from
individual invocations
or plots of some patterns
that are in our system.
As Slawek already
mentioned error
reporting, when you can see
arrows grouped by error types,
and you can directly go to logs.
And in the context
of Monitoring you
can also set up others on
certain thresholds of metrics
and other conditions.
And so the first thing that we
do is we deploy our function,
and test it at scale.
In our case, the scale will
be just 5 QPS for 5 minutes,
but I think that's
enough for testing.
And when we start that
we still realize that we
have quite a lot of errors.
It's about 5%.
And when we look at the
plot of memory usage
we see that the memory
actually goes quite high.
It reaches the limit of 500--
of 256 megabytes that we
allocated to the function.
So probably we
mis-configured our instances.
We just gave them
too little memory,
and image processing requires
the memory to load the image.
So probably we just
need to improve of that.
But let's first check whether
this is indeed the case--
that the errors were
because of memory ran out.
So let's go to the function
page, and let's view logs.
When you filter the
logs by error type,
we immediately see that those
errors were memory exhibit
errors.
So of course we add more
memory, we redeploy the instance
with a larger amount of
memory, and we test it again.
And what happens?
Luckily the errors
went down to 2%,
but they are not
completely gone.
Something's still wrong.
And we see that the
memory usage actually
went up in the second test.
It went up even up to 500
megabytes, which is allocated.
So it looks like we
have a memory leak.
And I will let you
look at the code,
and maybe somebody can find
where the memory leak is.
Does anybody see the error here?
OK, one person sees an error.
Let's see if others see it.
Second one-- OK, very good.
OK?
OK.
So some of you already
know that the problem
is that we create
a temporary file,
and we don't delete
it at the end.
So the temporary
file is created here.
We just generate a random
string for the file
that we are going to generate.
And it has generated,
we write it to disk,
and we never delete it.
So this works as I described
it, the first part,
but whenever you write something
to your local storage it's
consuming your memory.
So it's very easy to fix.
We actually just need
to delete the file
before we finish the
function, and that's
the fix that we applied.
And with this memory leak
fixed, we immediately see that,
firstly, we don't
have any 500's--
no errors, and also
the memory usage
went down even below this 256
limit that we applied before.
So the question is--
shall we now reduce
the amount of memory
for the function or not?
But let's take a look
at the performance.
We see that with more
memory, our function actually
runs faster, and that's
because this is how
we allocate CPU to functions.
The more memory the function
has, the more CPU it also gets.
And giving twice more memory
gives also twice more CPU,
so your function runs faster.
And in our case, we
would like to have
the system quite performance,
so two seconds of latency
is probably quite good, but
four seconds is a lot too much.
So let's stick to
this instance size
and this amount of CPU,
in fact, for their work.
So now let's take a closer look
where the function actually
spends time on, what's
the most costly part.
So we go to Cloud Logging.
We select an individual
invocation, we click on it,
and then we can filter logs
from just one invocation.
And you can see that
the majority of time
is spent on uploading the
file to Cloud Storage.
That's quite surprising.
Google has a good network.
Why would that be so slow?
And the fact is that we actually
used very bad compression type.
And by the way, this
is not a very good idea
to look at one
individual invocation
to analyze what's going on in
the distributed application
because this may be just
some random problems here,
and maybe in other cases
everything will work fine.
So it's much better to
report customer metrics.
Use Stackdriver, for
instance, and look
at the behavior at scale.
But in our case logs
gave us this information.
So the problem with
uploading to Cloud Storage
was that the files were big.
We used BMP file images,
which were about 7 megabytes,
while PNG took
only 10 kilobytes.
So the first optimization
that we can apply
is to switch that
compression from BMP to PNG--
very simple.
And by the way, also
this uploading speed
depends on the instance size,
because uploading data requires
a little bit of the CPU.
So you can also improve on
that by giving the instance
more memory and more CPU.
So when we change
the compression type,
our function runs faster--
almost twice, much better.
Can we do better?
Of course.
I mentioned that our users
are a bit weird, that they
don't like backgrounds.
They like black and white.
So we don't really have
to download the background
image on every invocation.
Let's just not do that.
And this is actually
the case that I
tested, without any background,
just black and white.
So we can download
the background the
when it's needed, and we
can download it only once.
And with this optimization we
save another 50 milliseconds.
And some of you may have noticed
that on some previous slides
it was 90 milliseconds--
or 80 for this phase,
for downloading the background.
And this is what I mentioned,
that one individual invocation
will not give you precise data.
You need to have
multiple invocations,
and that's why metrics are
always better than individual
logs from one invocation.
So now we can also--
I mentioned that it's useful to
move computations that can be
done just once to global scope.
So in the next step
I move to creating
of the temporary directory
into the global scope,
and creating the GCS
bucket object, which
is this-- we always use the same
bucket for uploading the image,
and also for downloading
the background.
So we can you just move those
two lines into the global
scope, and that will save
you another 25 milliseconds--
not so much, but still
significant maybe--
more happy users.
So to summarize, what
we did here, we fixed--
firstly we fixed the memory
leak in our application.
We increased the instance
size to give it more CPU.
We used better
compression so that we
don't spend so much CPU
time on uploading images
to Cloud Storage.
We lazy downloaded
the background image
because it wasn't
using all invocations.
And finally we moved
some computations
to the global scope so that
it's performed only once.
And while doing that, we
use the platform tools
to observe our systems.
We used logging, we used
monitoring-- maybe we didn't
use logging the best way.
We could have used
more monitoring.
And that's about
that, but we still
have time to answer
your questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]